My name's Carl Junot and I'm the head coach for Harvard Men's Soccer.
And we're here on historic O'Hiri field.
It's the final day of Liverpool F.C., over from Britain.
They've been training twice a day
so we've had quite a bit of interaction
and I think, from a coaching standpoint
it's been very educational and motivational. "It's been surreal. I'm actually seeing a lot of the players.
The first day I was here, Daniel Agger walked five feet behind me. You see him
every Sunday in front of sixty
thousand people on the television so
it's different it's cool getting  to see him in
person." Liverpool's done
free coaching clinics for anybody in the community who was interested in coming, focusing on education,
player development,
and they did it here on Harvard's campus in our
football stadium
and in our soccer stadium.  "Yeah, I've gotten to see a lot of the training sessions. Being around such
talented players is great. Also seeing the good training that the professionals have.
The excitement that they have just playing and training and winning and training is something that we
can translate to our own game.
It's been a fantastic stay to have them here with us. Just really good for the community in
general
considering we're just weeks out from our
preseason
I think it's great to build some
excitement around soccer
ant
huh
goes
Liverpool just finished their last first team training session this morning, so what
you're about to see is the Coaches' Challenge; the coaching staff from Liverpool F.C. against the coaching staff of Harvard.
I've never seen Liverpool staff play but I can only guess
they're pretty good but
I've only seen my coaches play, but I think they're all pretty good players.
players
Both of our assistants were high level players, Carl was a high level player,
so it should be a fun game no matter what.
You know, they obviously have the premier league
experience in international soccer, but I think we've got them in our sights. So it should be a good game.